I'm a [ __ ] student of War I know all
the boys from in that from Charlemagne
Achilles the number one Warrior of all
war of years
from then Alexander and Napoleon I know
them all I read the more I studied them
all I know the ought to fight I know the
Art of War that's all I ever studied
that's why I'm so fit that's why they
feared me when I was in the ring because
that's all my I wasn't Annihilator so I
was born for
and now those days are gone it's empty
I'm nothing
I'm working on being the art of
humbleness can you be with me that's the
reason why I'm crying because I'm not
that person no more and I miss him
because sometimes I feel like
because I don't wanna I don't want that
person to come out because it comes out
hell that's coming with him and it's not
funny at all it sounds cool I got my
tough guy I'm scared of him life is
beautiful but you have to accept the
good and the bad as being beautiful you
can't can't accept the girl then we lose
some of our life sucks Life is Beautiful
because life gave us the ability to just
know them in our journey in life we met
them we love stuff we cared about and
they cared about us that's that's the
purpose of life just enjoy what we had
while we journey through it because
sometimes we don't understand like what
is this thing what is my purpose why am
I here
well I have to go through this pain why
do I have to go to this field all the
time why can't it just be peaceful all
the time
then there wouldn't be life
I wouldn't be lying we have to we have
to take life at its term life on life
term not all life on our terms
you know we have to live life on life
terms
I'm aware that a lot of people next to
me and watch me and may look up to me
and think I'm a certain kind of guy I'm
a good guy but they have to understand
that I'm not worthy of praying only God
is worthy of praise and they they make
they do these things you look at YouTube
and I see guys have Mike Tyson Immortal
Mike Tyson God and um I'm not worthy of
that you are like hey stop I know me
you could think what you want but I know
not for somebody that would praise me
anything now I'm always just Mike
I was one of those people that worshiped
people because I had nothing
imagine how low I had to be the worship
but nothing
somebody that's nothing and I worship
them
and that's why I live the life that I
live now because
um you knew me 20 years ago you knew me
20 years ago and that guy's kind of dead
now
you know but that wasn't easy
you know that guy didn't want to leave
he wasn't leaving easy
he fought it he fought screamed and
cried and scratched all the way till he
died
you know
and I'm very grateful in order to
succeed they have to be flawed they have
to experience some kind of shame in
their life
that won't allow them to be in the
position they believe was overwhelming
to them psychologically and emotionally
and physically even to this day right
now I have to check myself always check
myself yeah
and I want my wife is my consciousness
why is my masculinity in a woman
my mother because my wife my mother
[ __ ] me up that's what my masculinity
is in a woman
why am I so overbearing to my wife how
much my wife might say this is a little
bit better and as long as you love me
but it's too much
I know she must think that you have to
be spirited and haven't gone but never
give up and you're still with life is
just a long line of puzzles that need to
be solved and then without that um
competition spirit
people are not going to do well and they
have to know about competition because
without competition to train them they
give in under the slightest struggle I'm
very happy and I'm very proud of myself
I I never understood my accomplishments
as a human being until last year perhaps
I never took myself serious and last
year I tried and it turned out really
well but especially now no one's gonna
fight people like talking now they get
on the stage they get on YouTube and
they start talking yeah and that's why
some people
some people are not made for handling
credit handling criticism they just not
made some people go off the deep end
when she criticize them yes some people
just can't handle it and some of the
problem most powerful people in the
world you can't handle it they're not
mature enough to handle criticism
my adversity inspired me to be more than
what I've truly was without getting my
head and think I'm somebody
and then I'm easily offended when I know
I'm nobody I could never be offended
bag for this and this is what he gave me
it's not like someone gave me something
I didn't acquire I wanted this life I
prayed for this life and I received it
something like this is all about change
you know you listen you can't continue
to being a comedian if you're not
sharpening your um your psychic up even
when you're doing it right here you're
practicing your comedian act you know
you have to continue to practice the
more you practice it it say if you
practice it every four year you'll be
better if you only practice it for a
month so the more you do it the better
you become listen the belief that you're
going to come back is magnificent yeah I
believe to know that we're going to wake
up in the morning imagine we went into
life like that greatness is the
willingness to die that's greatness like
you see these guys um
you know forget about suicide guy forget
about the guy just people your thumb
there's a decent people just decide to
kill themselves
you know
what makes the person does that and they
do a young age 15 and it's just um how
do you say it this is a 15 20 years
um you experience enough life to realize
hey I don't want to be here no more um
it's something about yourself that you
just hate so bad
any kind of killing is a form of
self-hate
if I'm killing formations everything I
say about if I call my dirty okay that's
because I'm a dirty
maybe that it's because I'm a [ __ ]
we reflect with one another that's why
people Inspire about the second we get
inspired
because there's a reflection of one
another and they allow us to know what
we can be every person every everybody
was in that asking for help is walking
too long needs Warriors oh god oh we
call whatever whoever now whoever
created that word God that's what the
person they owe this oh god oh this help
me please I don't care I fit that all my
life
yeah I said that when I was in the
stages of not believing I said that yeah
but I don't care all the non-believers
all the atheists when it's the last
moment of our life
we say oh God please help us
or whatever we call girl oh God please
help us or whatever we know that's
bigger than us we say please help us
even we don't believe please help us the
moon the sky the birds
help us never stop believing in yourself
so there's never the power belief is
just invariable and Pregnant probably
confidence breeds success and success
breathes confidence confidence applied
properly with the path of Genius
it's not like the belief it's real [ __ ]
I'm only here because I believe I'm not
nervous I'm scared
ah I'm scared yeah because I'm a scary
guy because I've been picked up in my
life I've been abused all my life people
did anything they wanted to me so I have
natural fear of not being safe yeah
that's just my that's who I am natural
it's no it's in my life that's who I am
so now I got it with this weird
self-confidence and violence and stuff
so now I'm sadistic because I'm afraid
I'm gonna get hurt yes animal now you
have to do have to do it spectacularly
for more people who want to see me do it
again and more people did the more I
heard them and the more spectacularly I
hurt them the better my life would be
yep
and that's how my mindset was and never
run away from love when love calls you
have to answer
because if you don't you'd be miserable
for the rest of your life
that's just how it is you're trying to
defend yourself from life it doesn't it
doesn't have work or you why not making
it fool of yourself what's going to
happen is going to happen don't take
life too serious you stress too much
you're doing something good thing